[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
we rep jakey's art hello everyone and
greens welcome back to GameSpot I am
here with the creative director of Nazi
Zombies camera Dayton hi deal my friend
doing really well actually
welcome to GameSpot and obviously we're
here with Ritchie bracamontes a Arden
Call of Duty expert
we got Jay he's he's somewhere around
here somewhere inside the studio we
don't know he's gonna be helping out too
but today we are taking a look at the
tortured path and we're gonna be diving
into chapter 1 and then what do you
think are we gonna make it to chapter 2
chapter 3 I that depends entirely on the
skill of our pro players well and this
is this is admittedly one of the more
challenging chapters in the out of the
series of the game and because we feel
like if you've been along for the ride
this this long way you've got the skills
it takes to it to get through that so
and this is this is a little different
than what we're used to in Nazis on me
so far
oh yeah it's it's significantly
different we've actually at this point
in the game we we feel like we've we've
proven our ability to end and the
players ability to get through the more
traditional zombies map and so this one
we have really gone innovative alright
now on how the game is played on how you
progress through the game on the way
that we we hid the Easter eggs and and
even some of the the reward system the
series has been has been revamped so all
right man you ready ready are you sure
you ready I'm ready
all right let's do this I think we have
a little bit of an opening cinematic so
I think we're gonna let that play
whatever you guys are ready up all right
great yeah let's see everyone's ready
Ritchie are you gonna go with sulfur
bonds you're gonna leave it as is we're
gonna leave it as is I'm just racing
mode again yes very cool okay we've got
our our famous bat agent and battle eat
the
general Hank Rideau is the head of the
bureau and so these are these are the
canonical characters that you would be
experiencing this this map with as well
as two of our other characters one of
one of the fun things about this map is
we've introduced the characters that
have been sort of the secret unlocks in
the past and everybody's wondering what
are these just different skins kind of
vanity stuff and you know every single
character that's been unlock plays an
important part in the story and so now
they've got dialogue they've got lines
and that and our important part of all
right let's go ahead and watch this will
retain composed entirely of the Dead is
torn across the face of Europe it's
fallen on us the newly formed Bureau of
archaic technologies to be the tip of
the spear in this fight we cannot match
this enemy blow-for-blow
but with the help of our new allies we
will strike where they are most
vulnerable we will be smart we will be
fast we will be lethal but we must do
more than simply kill our enemies we
must totally destroy
baby here we are all right welcome to
Spain we're back I'm gonna I've set it
mmm I think every call of duty stream
we've ever had
these cinematics look incredible yep
they look amazing so props to your team
they just look so hyper-realistic it's
freaky oh yeah we have got an incredible
cinematics team there it's a it's a
source that it has done everything we've
got a group called digit and it is a
they they do incredible job of both
capturing the facial expressions of our
of our actors and our characters but
also just making the zombies a little
really damn creepy and run up very part
where we're starting at ha yeah
this is not your typical like we've won
yeah one of the one of the important
things that we one of the challenges we
wanted with that with this DLC we wanted
to switch it up so that the the general
the traditional zombie map has you
you've got to get in and you've really
got to grind through you know a dozen
waves before things really ramped up
yeah and you got to fill it off and
you've got to get the right weapons and
and we're like what if what if we made a
version of this game where you could hop
in and in in 5-10 minutes have a
completely like enjoyable exciting
adrenaline-packed experience and and so
we've got these more like kind of
compact maps with with the waves that
the difficulty level ramps up pretty
steeply right out right out the gate
yeah
we we've got instead of the broad spread
of gun boxes with you know a million and
one different guns in each unique box we
we took the idea of the mystery box
which is kind of a staple in in the
zombie load so why don't we take that
technology and compact it down towards
the different gun types right so now
instead of 50 gun boxes throw there
you've got your pistol box
you've got your SMG you got your shotgun
you'll get your sniper and but it also
adds an element of randomness where you
don't know when you go to the the pistol
box which pistol you're gonna get but it
might be your your favorite tried and
true it might be something that's gonna
force you into you know a little bit of
a different play style so that's that's
like element one of how we really shake
up every game you go through there's
gonna be another one you're gonna see
and the next wave around I'll say I'll
save that one to chat when we're at when
that comes out now we we've kind of
gotten used to there's this this kind of
like a raid in step system right in the
previous right now should these two be
searching for clues in order to move on
to step two or is right now is it
essentially to survive the waves and
complete the objectives as they pop up
you know the the fun thing about
creating sort of a a box where where you
can get in and play how you want to do
it really depends on what you're doing
what you're bringing into this like for
most first-time players it would be a
case of survive and familiarize yourself
learn where the weapon boxes are I'll
learn where the ammo is and and learn
where that where the zombies are gonna
be coming through the the players that
have done that at that are familiarize
themselves now you want to start doing I
mean you know the the the professional
Easter egg hunters okay they go into
every single corner they they listen to
every little rustling from the lead
yeah and you know why is that rubber
ducky in the corner and and try to
figure this stuff out and you know
Richie depends what what degree you're
comfortable with I know uh
you know Jake and probably pencil sketch
this this level in the dark as one of
the designers behind behind what
happened here but yeah I'm gonna say for
now for them for our purposes here let's
let's just let's focus on surviving
should see if we can get through how
many maps we can cruise through because
they're both there's there are several a
lot to look at like I'm gonna be this
I'm not disappointed with that answer
all right now what are you guys
repairing here I see they're trying to
repair so okay so now we've got to the
the next element that kind of random
element yeah the the occasional rounds
in and every single might have three
cases where you're gonna get a randomly
generated challenge challenge you might
be an escort mission it might be a she
can destroy mission in my Z BIA protect
this area mission and it's gonna be
different every time you call every
single time you play and and yeah I mean
he'll will bring Zeppelin's in to take
you know shoot laser beams out of the
sky at you we yeah and so uh and so it
really is a case of every single time
you jump in it's gonna be a massively
different experience yeah and and so
it's one of the the qualities that I've
seen you can find up which is which is
gonna happen you will randomly get
things that are that are harder than you
could handle pretty good is this more
difficult than it definitely ramped up
like from the start it kind of just like
kicked my ass right away yeah which
again even narrative Lee and and on the
gameplay we're like this is we're in the
thick of it now anybody who has survived
up until now in the story has got to be
a pro player and like I was saying the
people who have been along the journey
thus far the one thing that's impressed
me about people who specifically zombies
players is they tend to be creative
problem solvers you know like there are
a lot of people that are there
which gamers a lot of people and twitch
I mean not the the streaming service but
the actual it's Adrenaline's there
people are all about accuracy
some people are all about quick movement
zombie players just tend to be more
flexible and and and that's that's how
you get in that's how you solve Easter
eggs that range from you know different
languages to different orders to
translating Morse code to you know
throwing a grenade in just the right
spot or and so the this means that this
type of gameplay where we're switching
things off where he you know you you've
got to make sure you've got a loadout
that can handle both a lot of damage but
also a lot of survival and so right it
means we're seeing a lot of players do
less of like okay I'm gonna go all
damage I'm like okay we'll get we'll get
the free fire but let's also make sure
that I'm bringing along you know a
revival to make sure I'm you know and so
so we're seeing a lot more kind of a
vivid kind of multicolored play styles
coming into this because you have to be
able to to flex with it at whatever
mission is don't I yeah you can see
already it's like breaking like
techniques and traditions that yeah like
I know already yeah and again these
cutscenes oh is that so so talk to me
about for you as the creative director
yeah
they're obviously some pretty wild
things that have gone on so far in the
first couple chapters right since the
game's launch what is it what is the
process like for you where do you begin
like that's that's so fascinating to me
we've come a long way so far yeah when
you first sat down day one how long did
it take for you to get to up until this
point I guess again sighs oh yeah I was
gonna say it's it's not a process that
you say we're done like it's just just
as your audience kind of evolves and
gets accustomed to different play styles
and different elements there it up your
story evolves with them and so i i'm i
lead with story like that is for me what
what drives a game that will make you
want to come back you know I mean you've
got always have gameplay gameplay his
first but that's something that would
there was our
you know fairly established so so the so
the first thought was okay great
we're we're accompanied with a world war
two game with a fairly straightforward
you know good versus evil experience
right there is there anything in that
existing world in that campaign that we
want to play with and you know some of
the other studios have said you know and
in fact I think we're the first studio
to make our zombies game so so
intimately tied with our campaign a
single player that we literally have a
character from the single-player
campaign that is recruited by the Bureau
you know it's it's our bad agent is is
actually a part of part of that story so
so starting from that spot we could say
what was going on at the time was there
anything
scientifically happening then well we
can introduce a zombie story was there
any one military or political group that
was in too weird a cult you know once
you start asking those questions it just
opened up to all this really exciting
stuff and I mean obviously you know
other franchises like Indiana Jones or
Hellboy have taken this and run with it
and so you know we considered those very
much kind of inspirational points for us
and and so one of the fun things was
deciding you know so many zombies
stories so many fascinating zombie
stories are about a plague about a virus
about some biological agents so so we
decided what if we go in another
direction what if we go somewhere
different especially because in the
1940s and 50s this was still not a very
well understood sort of science but what
was being dug into in that era this was
the the Atomic Age it's like when people
are uncovering what's the atom and
what's the power held between the these
elements and and and in Germany they
were making some incredible strides it
was going to come via the deutsche
physique as they yeah what kind of thing
we have to do a lot of this research and
the
why not have them haven't covered a new
particle and so I've actually got a
buddy at MIT they call it bounce all
this stuff off is this is this just
realistic enough to be if it at least
likes eggs into the theoretic we can we
have we passed this and so we've got a
material that is a mono polarized magnet
magnetic ore and it's a theoretical
substance that could potentially have
have one end in this universe and the
other end in another entirely separate
dimension and is combining electrons
with gravitons to create this new what
the German they're calling guys today
lost Nick it's amazing to see like how
much effort you guys put into it to like
I love it if you're gonna be making a
Call of Duty game right audience you
know and people get is so dedicated to
and committed to this why not put all
that fun story in it and so I'm have a
science picture all as fiction off there
as well as creative director on this and
so it was just a rich field to kind of
tell all this story so so we've got this
energy source and you can run it through
a dead nervous system and it activates
the primitive portions of the brain and
and all of a sudden we figured that out
we're like oh well you know what if that
isn't our kind of in-game currency right
why not get rid of the in a relatively
silly idea of zombies dropping money
when you kill them and have it actually
this this energy that the Nazis have
learned how to absorb and turn into a an
energy source that they can power to
open their gun boxes and their dates and
so really a lot of it just kind of came
together at that point and and yeah and
then and then you bring in there your
cast of characters y'all got to give
them their own challenges and and
struggles and why they're here and and
we really the first struggle for the
first few chapters of the game was can
we make this seem like this possibly
could have happened like this it was
hidden in the shadows yeah of history
obviously by this point now that we're
in the the tortured path and
in our last game in Berlin we really
have the undead step out of the shadows
and when we literally had dr. Strauss
flew in from his you know secretive base
to rescue the the SS leadership and you
and saved Adolf Hitler's life and and
now the war has taken a completely
different turn now we've changed the
course of history
right and now whereas in in in our own
timeline at this date there were parades
in the middle of Germany and France and
Spain now we're trying to get a caravan
through a blockade of undead that are
sweeping across across Europe yeah this
is fun so fascinating because you know a
lot a lot of the previous zombie
iterations in : Danny have been very
kind of like survival wave-based I know
the previous Call of Duty was a lot of
fun where you had the like Amy's oh yeah
it was very colourful it was kind of
wacky no money money yeah that Lee Ross
the team over at IWA really they they
hit an amazing nerve of just I mean
David Hasselhoff and and and the the
wonderful thing about having these
different Studios they do it is like
they they so hit that nerve so perfectly
and left it wide open for us to be like
okay we're gonna go scary you know scary
and historic and science fiction Lee you
know accurate and I mean if you have if
you haven't played this yet obviously
right off the get-go from the tutorial
mission that like horror element is boom
it's from a center and I remember we
were in the we were in the room
everybody was playing for the first time
for the review event yeah and I first
jump-scare all around the room you'd
hear like yeah yeah it was and then you
get it yeah that was something about it
because I mean it's actually it's very
challenging to scare people yeah and a
zombie way Matt because because they're
expecting zombies you're always running
you're always moving and so I was like
okay if we're gonna do a tutorial if
we're gonna kind of slow things down to
that I'm like we're gonna make that up
house we're gonna make it out as scary
is there to this earth event and we
played with we played with jump scares
and we we've still got them to some
degree but we really found after a while
when people are into the role of the
game the the scary needs to be something
different needs to be the fear of
something's chasing me and right behind
me right and and the jump scares I don't
know if you notice we've completely
dialed those down they just you know
they're more frustrating than scary
after after certain point and now
talking about kind of like jump scares
and sounds and stuff how important is
audio to you as a storyteller because I
know there there are certain instances
when you're somewhere you're in a room
and a zombie comes from the ceiling yeah
or zombie comes from below and you kind
of hear that that quick like yeah burst
of music that's like whoa okay
something's here how important is audio
for you when you're trying to tell us or
audio is vital is vital it is it's kind
of like the unknown hero and a lot of
games on in our at sledgehammer our game
our sound design team is award-winning
yeah they they are so pro they they're
very good not only at the orchestration
of the music's there but the those
subtle sounds the the crunching of a
footstep in the gravel the the moans the
the breathing like I was able to even
geek out with them and I'm like queso
just so you know our zombies don't
breathe per se right they don't they
don't have and so I don't want a whole
lot of Gatsby sounds but they can
definitely contract their their their
lungs and learns for you know in this
kind of primitive brainstem attempt to
scare ya to Utah you know and and they
totally got it and we're just able to
roll with those sounds as well so I know
I can't speak highly enough of our
incredible sound as I'm team yeah and
then I guess from sound we'll go to math
design when you're telling these stories
how do you go about creating these maps
cuz I mean this one right here already
kind of reminds me of a couple of the
multiplayer maps
I think Ritchie which is which ones that
remind you most of
you know what actually with all these
doings I'm thinking of a keratin that
one that was really okay a lot of
Windows are seeming places to hide yeah
yeah very very much a deliberate attempt
to say since this game is happening in
the in the same game world as our
Singaporean are and our MP really you
know we just had the attack of the
indictment we we wanted to have it feel
seamless you know and so so that meant
we we took a lot of strong notes from
the art direction in each of those in
each of those cases then so our map
design team our environmental artists
you know we're challenged on how can you
create a world where you're walking
through a building that looks like a you
know a war-torn edifice from World War
two it has to be so realistic that the
minute you see one of these horrifying
creatures like I think it's scary I
think it is you're there to be in a
real-world situation when a zombie pops
out then in you know when you're in more
of a cartoon doubt environment yeah yeah
so so that was the challenges designed
Zambia's that look like they are they
are literally stitched together from
corpses using the technology of the time
I think think we're seeing a perfect
example this is the boy which is the you
know it's one of our Sasson zombies from
the darkest shore that everybody thought
they'd safely let me I know more screams
from people playing as these guys
anything else the the best part about
them is they're actually similar
agent dai and these guys is pretty I
can't outrun them and they have people
like me yep yeah
the like usually one of the what are the
important things about about classic
zombies is they can never run fast in
you you need to always be able to turn
around and shoot them while you're
running
and so our team was just basically okay
well how about screw that I'm gonna
bring it something that they can get you
so you better be able to take him down
ya gonna wave seven you guys are doing
it this is are we feeling confident J
all right I'm getting the thumbs-up from
our pro over here and just as a reminder
there's only two people playing yep only
two but we we try to get four here in
the studio but for some reason it
doesn't like us the studio says no only
two may play so that's why I've Ritchie
our expert here you're killing it as
usual yeah Jay also and so yeah well Jay
Jay's an expert any recommendations on
the blitzes then he's gonna want to pick
up through here yeah yeah you definitely
the speed we got pests coming at you we
got in wheelers and yeah yeah at this
phase you're probably gonna be wanting
to use the uber spring in our pack a
punch machine said yeah that's that's
another interesting thing like in the
past where you have the gumballs and
that kind of sort of thing what made you
guys choose to change the way that
operates I mean those things kind of
still exist with the joke machines yeah
but uh things are a little bit different
than previous iteration cap of zombies
yeah we really like wandering one of the
core tenets of this of this game what we
really
to be tangible as your prank is is the
flow and the speed and and so our blitz
machines are going to you you've got to
uh if you're gonna go to the whisk in
its gonna lock you down and it's gonna
put a Joel in here and your hand and so
you've got like half a second do that
you've got to plan your speed with Adams
however right once you've got it we
didn't want to have a complicated a
sense of like well I've got to you know
analyze this and go to my Start menu and
give all these general we wanted
everything to feel like you get it you
go you get a new run and the the speed
and and the ability to flow through this
stuff is so so important before I go for
this type of gameplay oh boy j-just
packed punches pistols bridges down look
at that yeah yeah
that's okay this is what yeah Jay Jay
doesn't to be on camera BC such an
expert he doesn't want fans to come up
to him bro yeah it's okay yeah he's all
about the craft a professional player
the the the recognition is is tertiary
were you were you guys involved in the
e3 this year or did you guys get it
they have a super exciting now some into
black ops for yeah and and this was very
much her brother's a Treyarch this is it
was their show so I was actually there
and but you know it's fun to kind of go
more incognito and was walking like
crazy oh yeah this year it's fun to go
enjoy yeah yeah I go and uh you know we
got to go through and of course got to
play the black ops and yeah and meet
with some and and there were some some
fans that you know cuz I tweeted I was
out there that you know I got to to meet
up with and get some hands yeah the
zombies community is so cool like it's
it's
because this is a co-op game it requires
you to be tab squads it requires you to
be helping out it requires that yeah
this is not a good game for prima donnas
well and and and so yeah I've already
made some dear friends yeah just a
little being a part of a part of this
community there no we should not say
that they're the nicest people in the
world I mean we where you're passionate
you can be you can be a passionately
instrument as well but but but that
passion I mean that passion wouldn't be
there if we weren't creating something
right had inspired it right yeah like
you can almost gauge the the quality of
the game by it was definitely like an
experience for you guys right during the
launch of the game yeah like there were
there were some hiccups here and there
so for the most part everybody was super
positive about it and I saw that most of
the criticism we were like very
constructive people seem to be like that
mean you don't have a here and there you
know we went out on a limb with this
game because yeah the zombie players
like their traditional gameplay you know
and we're like we don't we with with
final reich darkish or especially with
the shadow throne like we feel like we
hit top marks with traditional maps yeah
but you know what
we're gonna we're in a nice place here
let's let's shake it up a little bit
okay
I think it's cool when you guys take
some risks like yeah having an HQ where
it's like all those players are inside
that hub world and stuff like that and
like I would rather have developers take
risks and try to make things worse or
have a little bit of hiccups in the
beginning then have something R it's the
same thing every year the same iteration
of zombies like this is so
we're only on chapter 1 maybe we'll get
to chapter 2 if that would sling is
taking you good hey that is a battle
right there was a battle he's that big
proportions
you notice you notice J is very more
than that he gets right behind that
spine if you gotta go for this spine
that will make the whistling so less
frustrating oh boy
low on ammo both of you richy's rocking
an mg42 rounded that just picked it up
Nate's complete we're we're almost out
we are almost out so now there is
charges one more iteration one more deal
CP yeah yeah oh yeah the final chapter
is coming and the all our questions will
be answered and but we're we're setting
up some really interesting conundrums
with this with with the tortured path
and some of which have not even been
discovered yet the and this is this is
you know I think I think my favorite
thing the whole team they've been
working so hard for the past few months
on this on this DLC and being able to
say it we've got in in our breaker we've
got a ton of monitors up we're watching
different streamers different players
going through seeing how close they're
getting to uncovering the mysteries and
we're cheering for the zombies right you
know I mean we love that uh communities
out there but we're like every time I
see whistling take down a player who was
about to solve that easter egg
it means it's extended the mystery by
yeah I know it seems like we're just
sadistic bastards cheering for the
cheering for the undead but game
yeah but you know that the community at
large is loving the the it almost seems
like the the kinetic energy of that
mystery grow yet with every hour that
passed without it having been solved so
in fact we even take bets on how long
it's gonna take before everybody finds
you know the the mysteries here and I
people know like like weird there are
some things that have to be done before
we can say it's all finished here and we
get our you know our final epic ending
cinematic we we need to put together the
sort of Barbarossa yeah before judge
that needs to be brought out in dad
we've got some death going on here now
was that the optional objectives yes so
so again you've got screwed in this case
you've got to defend the ideas are our
heroes have been able to they they
ransacked the the SS they're they're
storehouses in Berlin and they had kept
a lot of the weaponry a lot of the
energy sources that they've been been
collecting over over the years as they
have the the hilt of Barbarossa and so
without even really knowing everything
there was they said grab it all put in
the back of the truck and get out here
so there are some dangerous elements
here there are some things they just
know we got to protect these and we got
to get this out to our headquarters we
need to get this stuff out to Langley
right in West Virginia and and get into
it and dig out and resource what's
research what's going on and so that
that's given us a great excuse to say
well yeah you got to protect this stuff
you have to be able to you know the boys
off so feel like that was the toughest
one you guys got in the base but it was
definitely tougher in the basement scrap
down there yeah yeah yeah
and what's they destroy one of those
optional optional pieces that'll break
break you from your progress yeah that's
not be you've got to be successful in in
these missions or you will be
taken down I believe in you guys I
believe do you think do you think you
need to guys need to mix it up in your
specials maybe what do you suggest let's
see here actually back up I got low on
ammo so free fire might be we did okay a
good option there J what do you think
yeah
jack-in-the-box turkey and it's
interesting in this you will get those
from from some of your supply drops it's
a yeah you want to be wise with them you
do not wish to just scatter them around
this game what do you think are you
impressive far to people yeah yeah this
is actually really again this is built
for four it's it's it's challenging for
two it's brutal for one but you know
what I've already seen some solo players
out there oh boy
just just killing it on this and you've
got you got to know how to run turn and
fire have your tippy-toes there are some
guys especially even if the events we
were at previously playing alone yeah
and some people there's no you the game
can be you know can and italics BB beat
solo right but it is it is the the elite
of the elite are able to do that the it
is it is a lot more fun with the girl
right definitely that's that that's the
strength that's the strength this sort
of game this is it is at its heart it is
a cooperative and so that's that's what
we built that's where most of us that
the energy goes into so with with one
more DLC coming right how are you and
your team on the zombie is kind of
feeling how are things you feel like
you're wrapping up you feel like you're
closing the final chapter so feel like
the journey is coming to an end I know
the team is incredibly proud what we've
done and the we knew we knew we were
taking a risk we were we were
essentially starting anew it was kind of
like starting a new a new story a new
franchise and we knew you know Glendale
and the crew over at at Treyarch you
know they had their signature style
their signature John zombie
that are wonderful Li and and the iw
crew you know took it to it Zini
different different degree and so we
wanted to say we want we wanted to put
our fingerprints on this is what
sledgehammer zombies is about yes how it
feels the horror the the realism and the
the adventure and and the team is very
very proud of this we've you know there
were some challenges along the way I
think everybody in the industry was kind
of taken aback with thee with fortnight
exploding and yeah but we you know
looking at our numbers we got back like
right when when a lot of that was
hitting was when our shadow throne came
out and we actually saw a ramp up in
numbers the shadow throne captured
enough people's interest actually got
got some more fire going on that and so
we've got this this very ferociously
loyal community that's this excited
about what we're doing and hanging on
what's gonna be happening next and and
yeah we we really feel like we're you
know we created a universe here where
there are so many stories that could be
told yeah we've shifted from world war
two with something sneaky and dark going
on in the background - and we've just
opened up you know a 1945 zombie
apocalypse random and and so there's so
much they can be having there however we
are we are telling a complete story you
know this as you can tell this is
essentially an element of the rising
action on the tortured path right the
the massive climax that's coming in the
in our next chapter the final chapter
yeah is gonna leave leave people
entirely satisfied but I'm sure we're
gonna be hungry to to be able to come
back yeah to this to this universe if we
can and that must feel very successful
for you guys you and your team like
coming all the way to where you guys are
now it's us it's just such an exciting
like it's an exciting time for you guys
to be wrapping things up too for sure oh
for sure it was it was there was some
fear and there was something like the
the zombies community can be a pretty
loyal tight circle they've really been
you know there they were dubious at
first there was some some criticism
first which of courses that was was was
was on point accurate but yeah we really
feel like we've kind of been been
welcomed into the inner gates here and
we we talked about this pretty much
every year here cane spot oh I've been
here a little bit over two years now
year after year the call of duty
community they show up in the numbers it
is one of the most popular games on site
year after year this is years oh nice
bombers and a jack-in-the-box and a
grenade oh my god that is a yeah of holy
villain proportions but yeah every every
single year you see the popularity you
see how many players are playing you see
it's it's absolutely incredible yeah
it's it's and it's a very kind of lively
group to be that was it interesting
since its football season that was kind
of a header of a jack-in-the-box that's
Jay being just appropriate to the to the
season have you guys been watching the
World Cup in the office oh yeah oh yeah
feels a little weird not having the US
of A in there yeah okay cheer for that I
don't know you've been following Mexico
at all yeah we're seeing soon yeah
Gloria stuff my my Italian team did not
make out it's okay it's alright get back
to it all right
Richie how you feeling this is Round
three for you
pretty good it's got to pick up a new I
think you want a new assault rifle here
okay well gee are you seeing the like
the difference between this game and the
game you just play you know I I have
seen entirely different adventures
different tactics you're taking in the
by the way that was some good use of
jack-in-the-box very nice Jay those
jack-in-the-boxes he's an expert as
always
pandemonium so how often do you play
yourself you know I try to play every
day I try to get every but now I'm not
is that I mean Jay it's just like a
scalpel with this get a little bit more
of a baseball bat do you play alone you
just play with always I try to play with
others I'll try to getting on that but
sometimes you know you're just like okay
I need to pull this up there's there's
just there's nothing better than
actually being able to open up the
levels go through and I I'm in detail
yeah like I'm the geek that will go into
a level and like go try to see how high
I can climb and watch the sunset and
yeah get that feel you know which meant
I had to be you know physically removed
from games like Skyrim and and so it's
the best way like you'll know if there's
there's so much detail in these in these
maps are our environmental designing
level design crew is just OCD in the
best way possible about making sure that
okay would this be the exact sort of
technology that you could have seen
right there like I know we've got you
know the guy scrap it what what what
color of of wiring would then with the
Nazis have had to build this around the
brass container like you hear some of
the the best discussions ever just
walking around the office with some
attention to detail right once they
release the this is right now we're in
the a northern
we're northern Spain were in a with a a
Spanish winery and one yeah and and and
there was all kinds of research over
okay what what sort of wood foundations
would you go what kind of stones would
they have right go through that and uh
and and the funny thing is like are the
fans the the players as they go through
a lot of them will end up doing that
kind of research as well to see if
there's something you know a little bit
off is there something where they can
find okay you know what that you know we
one of my favorite ones in the in the
final right because we left clues
towards our our expansions towards the
DLC is in a lot of that and a lot of it
were photographs so you know we had a
picture of of the island of Healy will
end in the final right and and and there
were some very hiss to players who were
just like why is there this picture of
this is weird island it does not look
like a vacation spot right now they were
unto you yeah and so and so that is I
think one of the first instincts of a
Pro Easter Egg hunter is uh look for
something that it seems out of place
when you have something that's not quite
there and if you trust the game design
team it's not a case of oh they just
didn't do their homework I didn't think
doing that was like that was deliberate
and if you follow your own relics like
the coal is dating brothers I'll be
ready
it's unbelievable to see the level of
speculation level does this have a
meaning does this have a matter it's a
conspiracy I did something brutal
actually with with with Don Becka who's
our sound director today we came up with
a zombie language and just completely
messed up phonetics yeah and when you
were a zombie it's gonna be like
gargling and it's gonna half rotten
tongue and a larynx is hanging out of
its throat so so so you're not gonna
think along that but man the the players
have been able to they started putting
two and two together and said wait these
they're saying the same thing over and
over again what does that mean he
doesn't mean and that was brutal because
we don't give you subtitles for what
they're saying so you've got a you've
got to try and
record the language from their slurred
zombie mounts see if you can D go to end
and they've done it they've done it what
I believe it and it's only now we're
getting a lot of our more astute folks
in the community that are posting clues
for you to where where things are going
and our deal see I really hope that
everyone who's watching right now is
listening to the attention to detail
from the creative director himself this
is just you know you very rarely do you
get to see the details the nitty gritty
background of something like this you're
like zombie mode like like how much
detail can you put it this is awesome to
hear everything you're saying
yeah well it's it's you put it in
because you know it's what is expected
and it's it's like this is if you're
gonna be I mean the the it's it's an
honor to be a a creator in in a
franchise that has so many tens of
millions of viewers the attention to
tell you you're gonna be under sewing
eyes you want it to be the best possible
creation that you can can poured you
want to be something people will
remember you want to be something that
people will talk to their kids about you
know and being being the world's first
to solve this Easter Egg being that the
first to translate what was being said
and and so why not you know why not put
your heart and soul into it and do what
you're doing what is what is the
difference for you creatively when
you're writing you know writing
creatively not for a game versus for a
game of the : duty that's that's a good
questions I've published off and I've
got a science fiction novel as well and
and there's a it's a different degree of
freedom when you're writing for that
because because you're you you're just
expressing for yourself you're just
you're telling your own story well when
you're writing for for call of duty when
you're contract before the zombies
community you have to be aware of what's
been said before you have to be aware of
what's expected you have to be aware of
like what the community hates you know
and
because it's it's more a case of you've
been entrusted to kind of bring you
carrying that that torch it's it's a lot
like do you remember watching like a
superhero movie I'm not gonna name the
one but done by a director who just
decided to make it all their own like
yeah the Batman series where this
happened and it was like it was
offensive but it was like no this is our
Batman you know this is our you know I
think it's one of the reasons why people
so loved the Avengers movies and and
even some of the more recent spider-man
movies have been done by by directors
and push my teams who you can tell right
they grew up on the comics they love it
just as much as we you and so it's it's
it's more case of their writing and
creating for us rather than for
themselves and that's kind of what it
feels like doing doing this this zombies
game is like we love zombies we're a
part of this this is what we enjoy about
zombies you unlock the back line over
springin and and and and so that's
that's really the the I think the key to
being able to to lock in with the fan
community right is making sure that they
understand like hey we would not create
something that we didn't love and and
buy we didn't love I mean last the
community and and so it's it's a
different sort of pressure and and sort
of an honor yeah
do you feel like there's more pressure
when writing something like this first
is writing one of your novels or it's a
different pressure okay it's it's a
different sort of pressure yeah like
it's it's hard to say it's a more or
less
I definitely different Audie yeah yeah
well I was
I was a blizzard for about six years and
you definitely feel like wow there are a
lot of very critical eyes are gonna be
on we're doing and so so in that case
you're you know everything you write you
want to make sure it's it's exciting and
interesting
yeah and well-crafted but but you want
to make sure you want to take take
reference for the the feelings and
expectations of of those who are
invested in what we're doing and there
are people that have years invested in
the zombie mode you know and and you
want to treat that with reverence yeah
might get when it first came out I
remember how it was was a game changer
yeah they totally you know there was
here you had classic multiplayer in
classic two world wars yeah and then
that first time cuz I'll say I feel like
it the first one when it came out it was
hard it was a horror thing it wasn't as
in-depth as were seen now with the kind
of characters and and you know you're in
these kinda wasn't even a storyline
really yeah and there was no really
story yeah but I remember playing for
hours and hours and hours my friends
online yeah non-stop and it was like it
was a it was a whole new experience that
no one had no one really wanted but now
we need no it was kind of one of these
happy surprises it's kind of one of
those things were even the devs are like
you know it was it was a pretty quick
and easy thing to do to throw him yeah
he would send them like you didn't know
we wanted yeah well yeah and and here's
the fun part like like that experience
of like well we just stumbled across
something that is super fun we went when
the team and I first started playing
with these smaller maps with these these
objective based elements and and the
switch up we already love zombies we
already loved playing that but this is
this is the the first mode in wow that
I've had the team staying after hours
beyond the over time just cuz they
wanted to yeah and they're smack-talking
and they're you know
cheering and I'm like that we hit
something we hit something there and and
this is I think this is this may
being one of the the favorite modes out
of our entire time yeah don't get wrong
I love each of the chapters we've told
right but there is something about this
this quick fun reward area as silly as
it may sound I I love that that we've
got a zombie mode that you can win like
an usual survival modes it's you play
until you die when you win you lose
right yeah and in this way you're like
guess what you you go through it you can
win and they're the objectives and and
high five our folks you know they they
live and and want to fight another day
plus I'm here if you're you know one of
these popular streamers you're the first
one to figure out a clue right first one
to find an easter egg right there's just
so many so many different ways - those
are lots of is there and and again I
I've gotta get into this in Twitter for
those of you that love the survival mode
that love the endless zombies like like
hey we learned with Rustin house which
was with our little kind of preview we
put that out as a survival map yeah do
unlock that is just way fun and I mean
here we've got a bunch of little maps
and you gotta trust us we we're gonna
deliver but we're not just gonna give it
to you right right you got to be patient
yeah yeah yeah that's that's just that's
you know kind of kind of the
sledgehammer away right yeah you're
gonna have to fight like yeah like the
the hidden characters the unlockable
characters you would not believe the the
brutal brutal unlock and pass that we we
created for some of these characters and
and yet be the community is just about
it you know okay we are at with eight
here this is Yahoo I'm proud regardless
so we got a beautiful guys craft shimmer
going across the the pack punch there Oh
wave 9 and you got them winners this is
um
be fun yeah this is a good choice of
[Music]
[Laughter]
remorse you know what that's another
thing I'll say there are zombies in this
mode world war two in this game that
just make me feel just uncomfortable you
should be a sir you know should be
disturbed yeah they make my skin crawl
yeah the I mean they were I'm not gonna
get into like the philosophical you know
spin on zombies and Nazis in the horror
house everything but the we wanted to
make sure that they felt like they were
not some you know some sort of like
spin-off of a biological thing that was
one of our initial kind of art things
we're not gonna show mutation looking
growing things they needed to look
engineer oh and I wanted to see the
painful combination of cold iron
electricity and bruise and flames
damaged flesh you know and and the idea
of how can we take limbs and organs and
elements that were supposed to serve us
some purpose but twist them around
another you'll notice the moistures to
give them a praying mantis-like claw at
the end of their the limbs well what
kind of looks praying mantis ii in a
corpse
it's the spine with broken ribs on that
and so if you had the to think in a cold
monstrous way if you had a fairly
limitless source of what would you build
and that's one of the twisted things
about building a game like that is like
you have to put yourself into the mind
of the disturbed individuals that would
have come up with this and what was that
it was a drama all right all right who
this is all right guys we're in wave
nine a green wave nine I think
I think we're gonna see this one through
I'm always the challenge of having the
Tesla gun there because you have to
fight so hard to get the Tesla gun in
the final wreck final right um even
though I've got I'll have a pack of
punched you know beautiful gun and I'm
like but but the Tesla gun you got a
potential again it's hard it's hard to
just see it Oh mom okay you got a shield
down you got a shield down take that guy
Janos ik is exactly what I shoot oh my
god backing up my plane I'm stressing
out Oh
dangerously close that's the problem
with a flamethrower is you can't really
just kind of Duck and Cover yeah
[Music]
how is he still he went for the wait
till you see the whites of their eyes
situations he's like hold it wait for it
we had held an impenetrable shield on
him that is only taken down by the the
Ordnance bombing that comes down so you
do not want to waste a bullet on him
until that shield goes down good to know
hope you guys are taking notes at home
oh the the community has figured this
one out yeah last night before I went to
bed it was that it's incredible how
quickly the community oh they're
brilliant they are brilliant like we we
will sit and and stew over the
difficulty in there the hidden nature of
some of these mysteries for days on end
and the community is like okay ten
seconds we got this we're like damn you
brilliant faster no Easter eggs where do
those come in your process the we create
the structure first rate this story the
one thing we decided in in its unique to
our map is is the the core elements of
the story the main story beats are only
gonna be visible or only gonna be
happening if you saw the Easter egg okay
because we know that
the heart that's really that's the soul
of the zombie games if you just want to
get in and do survivor
that's awesome you'll have a fun
survivor experience but you're not
getting the the meat bones yeah the
story okay and so so so we wished that
was this story we'll build out the
levels and then probably some of my
favorite meetings with this with this
team or when we sit down and we like you
know rub our knuckles together say what
would be the most evil twisted you know
hard to uncover story elements that we
could if we could I cover I'm sort of
doing damage control on the outer ends
there we go is uh Jase to handle in it
yeah I'm just kind of like if we if we
get past this I have to ask our producer
on the back of for lots I'll be pushing
it one more chapter because we want out
we want to make this through I don't
know if you guys we got another another
jack in the bud I want to jinx it shut
up yeah we'll just wait till they coming
in yeah don't shoot that tank you want
to get that close yeah did you just give
him a high yeah I did
Oh burning whoa whoa Jay Jay run take
him down while you're bleeding out this
is the guy again
This Is It this is 10 right yeah well I
mean you take him down and then category
well yes out of there this is step one
[Applause]
that was right
that was beautiful I was only get Jay a
camera so we've cleared out the way we
could out the ambush you've survived
they're probably gonna be sending in
some some backup so now you just got to
get the extraction oh boy yeah this is
this is what we call narrative leave the
Dana ma you're not done take it out of
school my god over but don't lose them
right here oh so there's a camel
so you've got us around you got 45
seconds yeah
come on boys make it out there and and
and you can't be running you know willy
nilly ever gonna have to make sure you
know there's action points everywhere
y'all are working together I like it I
like it
I've anymore fresh out of
jack-in-the-box seconds Oh
25 25 seconds
all right the instructor created an
outline for where you need to be oh but
it's hot
oh boy well there you train it you kind
them they're in a will kind of clean up
your leavings here we go oh all right 10
seconds Jay 10 seconds get there get
there oh my god did you make it by the
skin of your teeth remaining final tubes
yes oh man well done
if I didn't make it and he did whatever
counted okay so now we've unlocked
chapter two yes we're on Chapter who to
here we're able to would you have the
time to maybe show a brief look at
chapter 2 well I would love to it's up
to you guys I mean these are your
cameras you're you're you're you're
paying for the lights okay
gwon luke said it's okay I say well I
say we run for it because this is you
just had an expansive little sort of
open field windmill to run out we're
gonna make things a little more
claustrophobic now we're gonna get a
little more
more tight on you I will see how far can
get here I'll keep an eye on the clock
we can go for about an hour now but oh
really about an hour to finish chapter
one now we're going what is this across
into the depths yeah yeah that's an hour
are we going are we going down they were
we're no way we're going we're going
places okay so so the the journey if
you've seen the cinematic where we've
just gone from Berlin down through
France down through Spain and we got to
the port of Malaga which is on the
southern coast of Spain okay we do we
got aboard the the last remaining convoy
of out of Allied ships because we want
we need to get these things to our next
stop the the southern seas are
unfortunately just teeming with German
u-boats okay and and of course the
Germans have figured out a way to create
a torpedo that is a delivery device for
the undead oh that's fun so so we've got
to get we've got the pieces of the sort
of ready to get them shipped down to our
our next stop far in the south and and
yeah you just got to make sure that that
package arrives do we have a somatic y
no okay now Wow okay
this is dark so one of my favourite
things I actually heard from from some
of the streamers last night it was a
group that was going they were trying to
solve some the Easter eggs I was both
got got really far actually one of the
players got seasick like the rocking
motion of the boat the splashing oh yeah
did you super good that is such a win
for our environment to you like you guys
are so damn good you uh you know
actually get mommy made one of our
players hurl so games are getting so
good water it's incredible because we we
had
I believe there was an article that was
written when sea of thieves first came
out that the rockiness was making people
physically every day yeah yeah she needs
help
oh boy wave one with this cheap cheap
shot okay shoot it's all good he didn't
have any any upgrades Slayer save the
day that's a pretty cool outfits
somebody's wearing yeah that's the
that's one of our character who had been
a secret unlockable character that you
had to go through all sorts of blood
baths - what - get him unlocked now he
isn't actually he is a recruit for the
for the bureau and is gonna play a
bigger part in AH in our story oh now
there's something that's very
interesting about this map did the truck
slide to one side now it did so certain
avenues are gonna be and and to add to
add painful insult to injury the they
can actually smash you against the side
of your neck
you know I'm walk you're right look at
this well you're not looking my screen
but we're walking tell ya one thing if
you time your ear you're kiting
correctly you can use that as as a way
of clearing outside all right because
they can block zombie no good tick well
they can block and they can smash right
oh sweet oh wow I'm glad you weren't
saying now is it just in that particular
or is there another area there's a few
guys around by don't know if there was
if they all smash people look at there's
another one that's fascinating okay that
is that's a cool map element being on a
boat in general is crazy because it's
like you can't escape unless you jump
into the freezing cold water like
Titanic style yeah you're screwed on
this boat honestly I think one of my
favorite multiplayer maps was the was
the USS
Oh
yes love that map this is one way to
stay warm oh okay I see flame oh yeah
is it weird like this map looks so cold
that I actually I'm slightly comforted
by a form a flamethrower all right so
what were the challenges now with this
map versus the last one so so we knew
that we wanted claustrophobic we knew
that we wanted us to nail this we wanted
tight corridors and but you you never
want your map to be frustrating in the
wrong ways right you never want it to be
a case where people are feeling trapped
or stuck in a corner and so so flow is
still it's vital you know you've got to
be able to feel like I can get around
this corner I can slip by this zombie
without getting snagged around without
getting hung up and so there was a lot
of care put into exactly how to make
this have the claustrophobic feel right
but still have plenty of you still
needed a space where you could run you
know a lot of that comes through you'll
notice we've got kind of some some
shorter ceilings like like just feeling
like you that's sensitive and I've seen
some of the streamers without even
thinking about as their plane will do
this ya notice and that's if you're
triggering those visceral responses you
know you you hit the right target now
that was cool to me they had holes in
the boats you guys gonna repair yeah
that's one thing what is that oh okay
and and and I get another way that we we
knew that we'd have tight space here so
it was helped by the fact that we knew
we didn't have we didn't need a million
gun boxes you know we've got our random
gun boxes these supply drops mean we
don't have to have a million Blitz
machines
all right the place to charge you up or
like we will deliver those
and and then again relying on the
player's ability to do create a problem
song and say hey if I've just got a
kugelblitz and and this pistol and an
ice pick
how am I gonna make my way through you
know the next pest round how am I gonna
get through what's going into and if
you've really got to be thinking on your
feet in this map specifically this this
map will make or break a lot of players
yeah so now here's obviously you are a
master that's a language there's so many
interesting words to say you know did
you there's a we got to study a lot of
German to kind of prepare for writing
this I I had to learn some German I had
you to pick up some of the trends
because because we wanted to create some
new proper nouns yeah you know because
the Germans are gonna create these new
words for the the electrician al device
you've got inside the horse now the
bigger kind of battery devices the guy
strapped in and so I relied on we've got
a couple folks on our team that are
German and we've got a German speaking
PhD at our and we and so so that's
always the like the first line of
defense but I always like to a word can
be correct but not be like usable
there's got to be a flow to it there's
got to be you know and so a lot of it
was a case of okay team we're gonna call
these you know guys crimes how does that
feel how does that play and and and
we've got even our they care the the
actor who did the voice of dr. Strauss
and this uh doke here he is a brilliant
German actor in fact he's he plays a
Nazi and probably just about every
single movie you've ever seen yeah and
we we got to a stage where we're kind of
buddies I've got his cell phone and I
can literally call them say uh Doe we
say this word for me we use this in a
conversation and and you know he's kind
of a in in his very kind of gruff
directly German sort of way will
immediately say no I would never say
this I would never say
and you think gay and you can gauge also
yourself don't what's anything that
sounds good yeah no maybe not that well
yep yeah for sure that's cool to be able
to feel like well hey can you say let's
work another fun thing I don't know like
it's funny because our game is called
Nazi Zombies but you'll notice in our
dialogue and in our text we never say
the words all right
the the German and researching that the
term zombie really got popularized in
the United States in like the late 60s
right and and so well you may have heard
it rarely you know before then you would
have never heard it in Germany you know
around this time and so that was a like
a silly geeky decision we made in this
game was like you know we're not gonna
use don't become the undead you know the
enemy will call them you know and that
was an interesting hurtle so in our
marketing will sometimes use right term
but but once you're in the under the
umbrella of our game you're not gonna
hear the word the word zombie right and
I mean for like branding purposes and
whatnot it's Nazi Zombies is get around
for so long yeah that's why pulling into
there sure is there's the immediate
recognition of that but you know every
every group has got their kind of
creative hangups I guess mine was I
think the team started hate me I'm like
no you accidentally said zombie strike
it you're like guys a top being like
alright no longer Nazi zombies okay it's
gonna be nazi undead to make their calls
that's you know and that's what we call
it what we did but but once we're in our
you know kind of our realm yeah you know
you're in my house now we're gonna call
it and you might notice the the subtle
viewer the zombie connoisseur will
notice there are some unique zombies in
every single one of our little maps here
I don't know if you saw there was a
zombie with a life preserver
yeah we've got some and
the same sort of thing exists in the
maps as well and that's that that's just
cuz why not right well zombies can drown
too
oh wait she's wrong word though no no
you can't hear you're not yeah you're
not in the game together killing it
already the response has been Oh awesome
we got the moist lers and then this is
where I've heard more of the win dog
swear words
watching the stream than than any other
part of the game what you've run
especially in these tight quarters like
these guys when their arms and claws are
fully extended
can fill up the entire hallway a
jack-in-the-box okay get over there
they're raising hell yeah oh boy I just
chucked a grenade in the wrong direction
bounce it in here now just like on the
floor in front of you this went live
last night yes no no we unfortunately we
got kind of hit by a little bit of an
unexpected thing so it so needed a
rolling release and so Oh folks in the
UK yeah got it before the rest of the
group and here's something I've got to
say it was a very impressive several of
them I sent messaged me privately and
said hey man I've got this I've got it
I've got it early it's cool if I play it
like like how amazing is that they asked
you to do that so and I lived under like
hey listen everybody out there has it
there's nothing I can say that would be
like you know that wouldn't be fair from
you say no don't play because then some
other jerk is gonna get up and play but
they were like super respectful though
you know half of this I'll go in I won't
solving the Easter eggs I'll kind of do
a little bit
around how cool is that right they were
so responsive to the community yeah what
wouldn't one of the gamers got and he's
like I'm just gonna play through and
then I'm gonna stop I'm gonna delete my
stream Wow and then I'll get in when
everybody else goes that was just I
thought that was just a class act and
and that's that's just good people third
yeah you know it's funny on slaying
zombies has brought us all together
truly but I was I was actually very
impressed that we were able to to get
that out man and so and so what I meant
was by the time the rest of the
communities out know Easter eggs have
been solved you know everybody still
felt like they got everyone's only get
first wait yeah yep yep all right you
guys got this yeah how many are left
around six that you just you got them
off they cleaned it does not like me
timeframe right yeah 22 22 seconds
simply amazing I'm fine no no thanks
there's some big gun guns right there on
my way it just it just throws so much
hot metal into the air right all right
now well those stay or those know that
you gotta you got a certain amount time
to pick them up or you are you are hosed
kind of like when you get the ooh if say
you can kind of experiment around and
play with what you wanna get you get the
big the big one Ritchie just enough time
oh my gosh yeah they flicker faust and
it just and and here's fine yeah we did
our research this was an actual weapon
it was actually something the Germans
experimenter with a something they can
choose multiple rockets in a serious
bazooka style yeah
I'm about to test it out Oh works great
yeah yeah you do not would you not want
to shoot that in a small hallway right
Jays just having jack-in-the-box fun and
bag
we have over spankin so there's one more
romantic lines I've ever used all
players are that or do you have to earn
it yourself
no once once it's unlocked what you
unlock the river spring and then anybody
can go and power up their weapon so
highly recommend you do that if you on
my way I'd actually find it
Oh down so far from the shade okay it's
down the creepiest part of yeah good
where blood is sloshing around your
ankles and I only have a rocket that can
kill us all
yeah duh rocket jump yeah so Lincoln
roasting up there yeah I'm sure the
players are gonna but can you give us a
little tease of chapter three what kind
of mad I I'm not even gonna talk about
this is this is like it's not there so
exciting okay oh yeah oh yeah this is
all my god
the underbelly of this [ __ ] and and and
I mean a lot of the community have
already discovered this as well there is
a lot more going on to this ship than
meets the eye oh I love that I said I
write as J pulled the eyeball out of a
gram behind me that was synchronicity
the because you're transporting all of
these like insane
Geist craft powered devices they
resonate on some really like
metaphysical frequencies which
completely mess with the human nervous
system and and can mess with what you
see in what you perceive and your your
sense of time and space and everything
else and so this uh this ship it's a lot
like the that's a good way of putting
this it's a you guys watch Doctor Who
not quite okay okay I'm sure people on
the office think there are there are
some interesting blue boxes and doctor
okay there are a lot bigger on the
inside than there on the outside and
this is sad this ship well here's a
question for you sure so since the
beginning obviously you've been writing
since the beginning what have been your
biggest influences you mentioned Indiana
Jones already right for this for this
project definitely Indiana Jones and a
lot of Mike Mignola's Hellboy stuff is
also built around that and and if you've
read the any of his comics like he does
an incredible amount of research for for
weapons for if he actually does even
like brave rubbings and gets a lot of
the the art of the time period to make
sure that because to understand anything
going on in Europe especially you know
the the battles of World War Two out
there you've got to understand its
history and and for this game you know
this this is something that is
been going on for millennia and so you
know we brought and obviously frederick
barbarossa it was the Holy Roman Emperor
and you know one time king of Germany
and and if you're gonna tell a story
about that well I have got this massive
four hundred page novel on on Barbarossa
and and I just I love history already
you know they're some of the best
stories are the ones that we don't make
up for the ones that we we tell after
we've survived them and the and so a lot
of just just the the actual history
itself the I think the strength of of
the Indiana Jones stories of Mike
Mignola's Hellboy it comes from the fact
of a very legitimate sense of history
because when you tell a story that is a
that is largely true historically when
you when you sag away from that when you
go go into the fiction that fiction is
more startling right you know just like
this ship is based off of an actual ship
like they every single bolt a and and
thing built on the ship is is true to
what was built so when you've got that
happening then when you see a crawling
corpse when you see something entirely
supernatural it's more shocking it's
more I think on a complete almost animal
nature we we feel those those panic
chemicals in our body when something is
not what it's supposed to run you know
right so you've got to have that setting
of the of the super realistic if you
want the surrealistic to that's it right
great so there's also an inspiration
there's also a lot of like like the King
Arthur story plays into this a little
bit know what th why it's the ones in
future king the the elements of you know
a lot of people theorize that Frederick
Barbarossa the the King Arthur story is
based off of his story you know the lot
of the historians talk about these
legends of Barbarossa sleeping under the
mountains and he will rise again to
bring you know Germany back to its its
height then that was something that
Adolf Hitler certainly believed you know
he built his his leathern home on the
hills of the Kaiser mountains where
Barbarossa was said to be waiting and
buried so surreal couple that's a great
bet for the story of yet another great
story the you know built around legend a
method of course we had Excalibur he had
his sword right yeah nice job J that was
a little stressful and now I think we
have another challenge here yet another
random challenge is it challenge time it
is a challenge tough huh catching on I'm
catching on yeah so this is a good time
to get a mode up and pack bunched and oh
no it looks like whatever the guys craft
energies are messing with your
perceptions of reality here oh boy what
oh no no you're high okay
oh geez I can't even describe like what
we have like asked you streamers last
night they're like what were the
developers smoking whoa
now you two also know hyper sped up too
right
hey you're moving quicker I think I am
I'm like everything just seemed yeah oh
no Ritchie's down Oh No
oh god this is terrifying oh we've got a
save yourself get worried he's not
stressed oh my god perhaps some kids
might look me enough to know how to
rescue people okay great great
now so close jr. lay down ah Wow I think
that's about sheer out that I think
that's a that's a fitting end they would
challenge you to do that
yeah I said it last time I'll say it
again so impressed by this guy and our
little secret caller here off camera
just bring our secret lair right here
cameras has been fantastic yeah thanks
for having us over this was so much to
play through a lot of fun with you guys
and I gotta say it's it's so interesting
and also refreshing to hear how much
effort you guys put into Nazi Zombies in
any game so it's it's written super
fascinating take you're like everything
you have to say is Wow oh thank you
thank you it's just it's we're lucky
because it's it's what we love to do I
mean this is the sort of thing you can
tell what it is it is our passion it is
the sort of thing that a lot of people
complain about taking the work home with
them and I love that I go to bed I'm
like you know very very lucky thing to
be able to do anyway for sure
yeah I like that any time
you know we the kids come back again
Thank You Richie you're the best year
you're killed it as usual I'm so
impressed I'm so glad I didn't have to
play today see my thanks camera Dayton
crib director Nazi Zombies it's all
correct yep yep correct Richie I'm Nick
thank you guys for joining we'll see you
guys next time right here at GameSpot
good bye
you